As we go to our next game
Siri MD. Siri MD.
A recent study showed
that A.I. assistants
like Siri and
Microsoft's Cortana really suck
when it comes to answering
serious medical questions.
Uh, although, it should
probably be no surprise
that you shouldn't trust
your health to the same program
you use to find
nearby mozzarella sticks
and anime porn. So, comedians,
what are some other questions
you should not trust to the
little person inside your phone?
In 60 seconds. And begin. Rhea.
Siri, why does Neil deGrasse
Tyson want to take the joy
-out of everything?
-Points.
-Cameron.
-Siri,
what's the best way to sync
my wife's period to my period?
Points.
Aren't you just supposed to,
like, blow your own hormones
into her face or something?
Like... (blowing)
No. No, Chris.
Not into her face.
-Jenny. -Siri,
how do I get One Direction
-to give me a hand job? Yeah.
-All right, points.
-Cameron.
-Siri,
what should I do
with this O.J. knife?
Points. Rhea.
Siri, where is the closest
diner, drive-in, or dive?
Points. Jenny.
Siri, do you think Marco Rubio
has stopped crying yet?
-Points. Rhea.
-Yeah.
Siri, where in the world
is Carmen San Diego?